in this episode i asked logan paul what
seemed to be one of the most difficult
questions he's ever had to answer
[Music]
[ __ ] what a hard [ __ ] question dan
hey i'm don miss i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
that's logan and that's me at a bar in
cape town south africa in january 2022.
logan paul is a lot of things and he has
done more than most could in a hundred
lifetimes
but i don't care about that [ __ ] anymore
before meeting him i had a really skewed
perception of who logan paul is anything
but a true artistic creative right i
thought he was someone only interested
in the limelight in front of the camera
but that all changed one night in cape
town at this bar when logan told me
something that would change the way i
look at everything i create ever again
and in turn the way i now know him as a
great friend and without the loud music
drinking and chaos i'd like to share
logan's genius with you well i would
like logan to share it with you the idea
for this video wasn't yet in my ideabook
so i'm just going to write it in here
how to care less and make more
as a person in the creative world i aim
to make work that deeply expresses my
inner self
but i constantly fear what the audience
is gonna think
i need to take the [ __ ] craziest
coolest photo i can every single day for
the next 99 days on a polaroid
with the launch of logan's 99 originals
project it's the first time he is seen
behind the camera
essentially it's him coming out as an
artist not the hype man and entertainer
everyone knows him as this is him
fulfilling his creative calling but is
he scared about what the audience is
going to think like me or many other
creatives would be let's see if logan
paul can get me out of this conundrum
[Music]
how you doing i'm good bro how are you
doing
good dude yeah [ __ ] yeah dear let's
[ __ ] let's kill it
so i guess i just wanted to start off
with asking a question what creativity
means to you such a hard question i know
i hate that question no it's all it's
all good i guess i've never thought
about it and i want to give you a good
answer let me think what what does
creativity mean to me
i get excited by creativity and why i
value creativity so much is because
there's no there's no limits i feel like
it bridges the gap between the
attainable the unattainable reality and
things that aren't reality and somewhere
in the middle of that that is creativity
i've been creating for almost my entire
life whether it was uh writing whether
it was taking pictures since i was eight
years old i can remember my first time
capturing anything was on a digital
camera and then it turned to video
camera then all of a sudden i was doing
it for eight years i got famous on vine
and then this media spin-off happened
and i was able to make a life out of the
thing i loved most which was creating at
the end of the day you know i'm a
creator but in my adult life i've
evolved i believe from a creator to an
artist and i manifested that with 99
originals
amazing research what is 99 originals 99
originals is an nft art project where i
traveled around the world in 99 days
traveled 85 000 miles i took 4120
polaroids and selected 99 finals to be
turned into nfts that i'm gonna auction
off one by one over the course of 99
days where
the buyer of the nft gets the physical
original one of one polaroid so it was
my way of combining digital and
traditional art stories that i cannot
show but i can write because they were
so
deep or transformative for me
while i was going through this what
truly was like a manic episode
and so i have just notes
hundreds of hundreds of pages of notes
of ideas of this project that manifested
into uh what i believe is an amazing
amazing body of work
honestly out of anyone i've ever met you
by miles the most resilient person i
know
and like i swear to god and like
especially moving into the art space how
do you deal with critics in the industry
of art there's so many people that go
that's not art
like this digital form this is [ __ ] i
well i appreciate yeah i mean bro not a
lot of people have have seen it because
you know the stuff that i've created
mostly is commercial a lot of people
don't think about the ideation the
conceptualization the execution the pre
and post work that goes into all the
stuff i do and with a project that is
more art first
ie originals it's going to be a bit more
easy
for people to download that oh okay he
he's
he's a bit artistic he has an eye for
something we're not sure what it is yet
but there's something there not just
being [ __ ] vlog fight guy
it's not just about attention now it's
about the work everyone has an opinion
but at the end of the day
personally i know who i am
i believe in my work and it makes me
really [ __ ] happy to put it out
everything else is just noise like i
don't care that's where i struggle i'm
so scared
of what people if they comment that they
don't like that person on the screen
they're telling me and i can't hide
behind so much no but no but i mean bro
who [ __ ] cares like
like honestly who [ __ ] cares bro dan
i've met you
you're dope you can't please everyone
you just can't bra this is like a super
weird example but okay i love beyonce
beyonce
beyonce i would also assume that
everyone loves beyonce i was at
coachella once and it was like beyonce
and like skrillex performing at the main
stages and i saw people walking away
from beyonce i was like where are you
going it's beyonce and they're like i
don't care
it's it's beyonce and i'm like
wait what they're like yeah she's not
for me like i just don't like her i'm
like how can you not like her and that's
what i realized such a weird example
that's what i realized i'm like yo you
can literally be
like the perfect person who makes great
art and stands behind
a body of work that is second to none
and still people are not gonna like it
so the moment you stop trying to please
everyone i think there's a real power in
that like real power in that
um
take the [ __ ] leap man
you know
take the leap like
you create something that you love if
you really love it
who really cares if other people do
as long as you do and if you really
believe and have the conviction that
your piece of work is paramount
go for it
post it press that publish button
amazing bree i think that's it no
problem
peace dude thanks again
take it easy
for sure
bye-bye
i'm gonna send this polaroid of logan
and i to one person that subscribes to
my channel turns the notifications bell
on and then comments below letting me
know that you've done so and yeah i hope
you enjoyed logan's insight into how to
care less about what people think and
make more of what you love and before
ending this episode i just wanted to say
a huge thanks to discovery plus for
partnering up with me on the brew show
and making this all possible all the
brew show episodes are uploaded on
discovery plus before they are uploaded
on my youtube channel so if you want to
head over to discovery plus now and
binge watch the next four click on the
link in my description and if you sign
up now you get a 14 day discovery plus
trial using the promo code dan mace this
offer is valid until the 25th of june
2022 and lastly if you like logan and i
and love the crypto world or highly
interested in the nft space i would
highly highly recommend a new
documentary called dead man switch which
you can watch now on discovery plus so
yeah click on the link in my description
to redeem your promotion now and yeah
don't forget to subscribe turn your
notifications below on and comment below
other than that don't forget you're
awesome brew and i'll see you soon
[Music]
you